welcome back to las vegas now solomon
thomas is a defensive lineman for our
las vegas raiders and he is the
co-founder of the defensive line a
charity dedicated to raising awareness
and securing funds for mental and health
and and suicide prevention something
that hits close to home for him solomon
thomas joins us live to tell us more hi
solomon
hey how you doing good thank you so much
for joining us and this is a really
important conversation to have i know it
hits close to home for you let's talk a
little bit about the defensive line and
why you started the organization
yeah thank you for having me on today
yeah the defensive line is you know
organization my family and i created you
know my mom dad my cousin ray and our
mission is to end epidemic use suicide
um you know uh where young person dies
of color we're no young person of color
dies by suicide um but we're doing that
by you know um recreating these programs
for
uh um you know mentors of the youth
because we're focusing on you know the
youth and going in schools and to create
these programs for mentors of the youth
um when whether it's teachers you know
coaches you know in business and
classrooms locker rooms so we can teach
you know these people how to have you
know be equipped with the language to
talk about mental health to
um you know be able to um you know show
resources you know whether they're um
you know certain situations where you
need to have like you know crisis
situations or so and i'm just creating
healthier a healthier environment of
mental health um so you know that's kind
of what we're doing and you know we're
excited to be in our first year kicking
off and i'm going to try to make some
changes
yes congratulations on the first year of
the launch and you recently did a talk
shop talk with your parents tell us a
little bit about that and and your
sister that you unfortunately lost to
suicide you guys are very open about
sharing your experiences in hopes to
help others
definitely yeah so we were able to be on
talk shop live
a few days ago and it was that's a
really powerful conversation you know we
were able to uh you know be asked
questions from fans and just just anyone
who joined the conversation they were
asking very you know serious and very
engaging questions you know about mental
health about what we're doing at tdl um
you know so it's exciting just to see
how involved people are and how serious
taking mental health
and just how they're supporting us
without that meant a lot but you know my
big sister ella she died by suicide uh
january 23 2018 and um you know it's
kind of shocked my family's growing and
um you know we didn't know much about
mental health you know much about
suicide during that time um you know we
we learned so much throughout our first
year of losing ella and we were like you
know there is a big gap and a big
problem in our world with mental health
that we want to be part of the reason
for change we want to make the world a
better place you know we learned all
about the stigma mental health about
people not talking about it about people
stigmatizing it um so we wanted to you
know you know stop that and erase the
stigma and let people know it's okay not
to be okay that um you know that you
know you're perfectly imperfect the way
you are um you know how you feel um you
know you're showing your feelings for a
reason and it's important to sort those
out you know it's okay to get help it's
okay to get therapy it's okay
to um you know you know to work on these
things because we're all going through
it um in one way or another and you know
it's important to normalize mental
health you know to make the world a
better place
well thank you so much for sharing your
story and being willing to be so open
about it and for people who are
struggling or need someone to talk to or
maybe just someone who wants to help get
involved with your organization where
should they go
um you know please go to
thedefensivebond.org that is our website
or check out our instagram at the
defensive line um you know you can
always i'll always be reposting it at my
my instagram as well at sally thomas90
um but yeah we appreciate any support
any donations and just you know getting
the word out that we're here to make a
difference thank you so much solomon we
really appreciate you taking the time
and we're sending you and our family
your family all our love
thank you so much i appreciate it